good night when you go out in Vegas and
you see a pretty girl at the bar you
can't go up to her and the opening move
is like here's my key let's go [ __ ] yes
sir what's your name my name is Jeff
thanks for thanks for taking my question
show me on kind of talking about what
would you do for your mother and then
for your brother yeah for a complete
stranger yeah yeah 32 I started a
company called red monkey foods we do
form a seasonings and spices so since I
am a complete stranger would you mind
tweeting about it to your 900,000
friends see what I find interesting is
even though I just gave it a really
passionate talk you went for the 19 year
old dude
[Applause]
good morning how are you guys awesome
thank you thank you so much for having
me I'm excited to be here actually I
have a funny intuition let's let's start
with this by show of hands how many
people here have no idea who the [ __ ] I
am
raise your hand that's what I thought
well great brands don't exist there's
the people running the brand if here's
coca-cola that's some boring ass content
it's the CEO of coca-cola is interesting
the sales kid in the market of coca-cola
is interesting like so I think of it
like the office or Sports Center on you
know anchors right the people like
office the sitcom right like like the
amount of how many people here have more
than 10 employees great all these people
have companies in those 10 employees you
got some [ __ ] characters that we'd
love to put some camera on you know and
so to me it's the humans make up the
brand they're the brand can't make
content your jean jacket is a brand but
like it can't talk so it's the humans
behind the brand you can make it more
about the office environment less about
the individual person if you want to go
there and you do that as a programmer
right you give equal bullying billing on
the 12-minute video to the to the front
desk person to the CEO to the person
that cleans the carpets to the customer
how do you story tell is up to you but
absolutely like that's how people get
like into brand always outpaces sales
this is a room full of people that
understand sales
I understand sales but the ultimate is
brand when it comes to you you got from
Hey good thank you that's for better eat
it Babineaux yeah so I actually but to
work with them and it's coming from
somebody who give all your content now
give all your secrets out like why do I
give away all my best advice for free
why should people work together because
this is an industry where it's so hard
to see anything secrets away at the same
time I mean because doing the right
thing is the right thing
karma is practical you know I heard
somebody rant earlier right that's like
hey when I win I don't think it's coming
out of you the guy that closed I
couldn't know who was on stage but I
believe in that right because I love the
idea of 85 people here going and
listening to me winning I didn't make
anything for it but it then becomes
brand if she goes out and listens and
then two years later she's having dinner
with a friend and she's talking about
what happened to her life that friend
might be the CEO of GE you know I'm
playing with the biggest brands in the
world I'm not trying to monetize my
audience I'm trying to like just bring
the most value in the world and let that
lift all my other opportunities so I
think I think giving away your best
secrets is the greatest rata G for two
reasons karma is practical and leads to
more business but here's the secret and
it's even funnier 99% of these people
are not going to do anything about it
the reef somewhere about five or six
years ago I realized this fact holy [ __ ]
people aren't going to do anything with
this so [ __ ] it like there's still gonna
be plenty for me and I'm gonna be the
most lovable guy ever I love this so you
know giving away your best advice is the
business development because then it
become the reason people work together
is because it's nuanced right you're I'm
giving all the best advice but then when
if I step down what I'm about to do for
that dude right is we're gonna really
look I know I'm theoretically right but
I don't know the details of what made
his twenty thousand not work I got a
look and so there's always one extra
step when you look under the hood
there's the theoretics of how you fix a
car I can tell you everything about
fixing a car but until I look at your
car and look under the hood I'm like oh
it was this part my friend
[Music]
Pyare Mohan do you really think that was
a good idea I know bro I honestly think
that that was one of like the worst
moves I've ever seen because I'm not
trying to razz you I am talking I'm
trying to give you love I love the
passion to win the problem is you tried
to close on the first move you brought
them no value and you asked them to
bring you value like you gave like I
will stand up here and give a [ __ ] load
of value and never mention one time for
any of them to follow me and a lot more
of them will follow me then they're
gonna follow that [ __ ] move that you
just did
[Applause]
I get it I get it but this was back to
the question that just happened this is
why I want you to win that move is
always gonna lose you can't go tonight
when you go out in Vegas and you see a
pretty girl at the bar you can't go up
to her and the opening move is like
here's my key let's go [ __ ] but but
that's what you just did let him hold it
but that's what you just did to this
audience with business maybe yes yes
[Music]
smart smart you can rip whoever's doing
your your YouTube show or like the
technical person can rip the audio and
then upload it to video and I did that
for a long time but let me teach you
this it was also not as effective as
when I changed my style I used to do the
askgaryvee show and I would rip it and
that would be my podcast now I'm doing a
lot of different things that are more
podcast native and my podcast has done
better but it is an absolute right first
move it's a great great thought and
that's exactly what you should do you
should strip the audio out of the
YouTube show and post it as a podcast
100% great start
there probably is you're gonna love this
about me I don't like to talk about [ __ ]
I don't know right there's a reason I
got these and F's it's cuz I don't focus
on dumb [ __ ] right you can literally go
to Google right now and type in how do I
strip the audio out of my youtube video
and put on a podcast answer by the way
that didn't embarrass you first of all I
appreciate like the gangster nature of
it I just want him to win I just know
that moves not gonna work you know
that's all that's all he's not
embarrassing I kind of [ __ ] loved it
alright let's do it thank you you can't
you can't you can't what you can do is
you can hustle and then people will
either ride up to it or run away from it
like you know I don't judge my people
first of all nobody that works for you
should hustle as hard as you period you
want somebody to hustle as hard as you
that works for you give them the same
economics you're taking home that's the
truth number two with kids rich kids
aren't gonna care as much as you about
money because you didn't have any and so
you had a fight for it and then that's
just real so I think you said I set the
tone for my company some people rise up
some people find their work-life balance
some people bounce I'm not in the game
of thinking that's important if I feel
good about what I'm paying somebody for
for what I'm getting in return I don't
need to judge that they need to work
harder so I don't want to get a deal for
my people do you understand
I want mighty people to be on my team
not me getting more value out of them
it's a huge mistake of business owners
hey Cho thank you better respect I
respect that number one you have to
understand that that gentleman right
there Scott when he's on Facebook and
he's on Instagram he's a different
person he uses Facebook for one thing he
uses LinkedIn for another thing he uses
Twitter for another thing you have to
understand the psychology of a person
when they're consuming your content cuz
the context of that matters number two
never put out a piece of content ever
that is in your best interest and not
your audience's the number one reason
that 99% of you are losing is because
you put out content that is completely
predicated on this piece of content is
going to make me a sale content is that
an abundance people want content that
brings them value educate don't sell so
I put out content that's valuable that's
why people like it then that leads to it
it's patience the lack of patience with
people's content understand the context
of where you're putting out content make
the content about them if you may the
[ __ ] you know who's gonna win in three
years on Facebook in the storm business
the person who makes the video that
everybody in town sees 24 hours before
the storm that says here's how you avoid
having me and Mike and my competition
come to you and have to fix your thing
do this do that do this then you're a
resource for them everybody in towns
going to see that and then when 90% of
them don't 80% of that 90% is going to
reach out to you
100% everybody's given free expect you
know expect I mean we know what you're
doing
you're free is [ __ ] loaded nobody
wants your [ __ ] loaded free dick love
you makes me come here come here come
here
you know I'll somebody do a face hey
James it's Gary Vee I'm here with your
dad
I'm really [ __ ] pissed that you're not
here but I respect that you're hustling
that's exactly what you should be doing
hope we get to be see it
[Applause]
[Music]